we should have a segment where we talk
to each other where it sounds
contentious
fake fake contention all right then okay
fine i'll ask you do you have a poll i
do i have two good i'm glad to hear it
great who's got the best chance no not
yet i haven't introduced michael smith
brother for another coming up right here
on nbc sports on peacock great to have
michael smith back here how are you
michael
i don't want to interrupt you i'm
enjoying it first of all rich
i agree audio on satellite radio does
feel a little redundant
i mean we're allowed to say that i'm
with you you know what i mean it's
obviously audio
but we're we're glad to be there it
doesn't you know what i mean there may
be an eye and michael and i
and smith and i and rich and i and eisen
but we are team players sir
you know what i'm saying absolutely but
that's exciting so serious 211 today
that's exciting
yes uh no yeah i wish i could have been
in the same room with you guys just now
i
actually i just wish i were watching
because i'm on the you know on the phone
good old fashioned landline
yes but that was hilarious just now so i
hate to interrupt but good to know we
just came up with a new segment that's
what we do here on the show as we use we
use the live
content live on air content fake
contention you know we'll do that uh
that'll
coming soon to a show near you uh ask
the poll questions because i do believe
they they do dovetail into some of the
topics that yeah
one nba one nfl michael perhaps you
heard uh lebron
re-up with the lakers so did anthony
smith who's got the best chance to beat
them in the west
clippers mavericks nuggets nobody
uh i'm gonna go with nobody i'm gonna go
with nobody
um 36 yeah i think the only thing that
can stop this team
this year is the stating the obvious
injury or since it's 2020 some kind of
covet craziness
right um but it i just
i can't remember i've been racking my
brain trying to remember a defending
champion
that was as good as the lakers word as
much as people try to take away from
what they did because it was the bubble
or because you know certain teams like
the aforementioned clippers
uh didn't handle their business or in
the east milwaukee didn't come out of
the east as many expected
with the two-time mvp as much as people
tried to pick at that title run
they were a really really good team had
obviously
headlined by two first-team all-nba
future hall of famers
two of the top five players in the nba
right now well i think if clay hadn't
blown
out his achilles we would have thrown
the warriors in there and that would be
the choice there you go you know
but then they come back and they get
younger and better
i mean who does that you know so i have
a hard time seeing
you know and the warriors would have
made it interesting rich i'm with you if
the warriors could have come come back
in full strength
and added to james weisman it would have
been nice to see him square off
um you know for for western conference
if not nba supremacy
but no i don't see anybody knocking off
the lakers not this year not anytime
soon because i think lebron is going to
be the the first player that i can
remember
maybe since uh you know since jordan
i'll have jordan's career stats in front
of me but i don't think he have a dip
below 20.
lebron will never average below 20 uh
and if he does it'll be because he
decides to have his damn near 20 assists
so i read an article about his mortality
and the reason why he signed the
extension
but i get it because he's you know wants
to make sure he gets all his money
before the end of his career but
mortality is a relative term when you're
talking about lebron james so
this team is is about to go on a serious
run
and make that ajo debate uh mj lebron
that much more complicated well how
about this twist on the mj lebron
conversation
michael smith um how about this is that
lebron
has beaten jordan in one way
and that is setting up the end of his
career scenario
the way that he has set it up to win
championships in the spot where he
wanted to be
and jordan did had to feel compelled to
just leave
for a second time like he that's that
that jordan did not have
in chicago at the end of his career in
chicago the ability to keep the coach
that he wanted and have the players
around him that he wanted
and win more championships because
that's what he's all about and lebron
you know obviously vogel is just his
coach i don't know if that's his choice
or not or that he's demanding it
in the same way that phil was obviously
for for michael
but lebron's set up he's set he is set
up in a way that jordan i think
wishes he would have been at the end of
his career in chicago it's funny you
said it
i'm still a jordan guy me too but but
i'm over trying to
debate them but funny you said that
because uh the number that jumped out to
me yesterday after this extension was
that by the end of it
he will have earned lebron 435 million
over the course of his career most all
time goes without saying he's still
underpaid and frankly
for the first what 12 years but not
frankly fact
as a matter of fact i should say first
12 years i don't believe he was the
highest paid player on his own team
um but i love where you're going there
rich and actually i was thinking about
that today myself
i marvel at the the mogul
on and off the court and the manipulator
the master manipulator
that lebron has been throughout his
career i put it to you like this
we can debate whether he's the best
player of all time
but nobody maybe in professional sports
history
has ever played the game and by the game
capital t capital g has ever played the
game
better than lebron james when you want
to talk about
the moves he's made as a philanthropist
as an entrepreneur
as an entertainer and to your point
roster construction
moving from organizational organization
uh
constructing his contracts to to
maximize his leverage over the teams as
he sees fit
uh helping uh you know his
is his good friend and fellow mogul rich
paul and maverick carter
established an empire with clutch sports
and uninterrupted and so on and so forth
we can go on and on uh it's just
incredible what he's been able to do
on and off the court in terms of just
the business of basketball and sport at
large right and set up
uh himself for the end of his career and
set up uh a client of clutch sports and
anthony davis
uh right right change his legacy right
and then
you know uh clutch sports is i mean you
want to talk about
he has wired the board he is wired
to kick it all off yeah because that's
when his contract is up
so he will be able to go wherever he
wants if that's what his son wants and
that's what he wants
unless of course it's the knicks then
he'll tell them to go pound sand but
other than that you know
it is truly amazing uh what what what
it's all done um
so you'll talk a little nfl and
obviously the the russell westbrook
uh john wall i guess in in the light of
what we're just talking about here with
lebron and the lakers the way i started
the show is
it that's just rearranging the deck
chairs pretty much but we'll just see
how that all does work out when it's
said and done
you know it is but it's interesting
though oh no doubt
no doubt sometimes sometimes you can
rearrange furniture and it looks like a
whole new crib
you know i was like wow i had this much
space
all right like the light hits the room
differently you're right from here
you are right i mean i i'm fascinated by
i don't know if we realize what we've
witnessed with this trade
which is it's it's unparalleled in many
respects so i think i read this on nbc
sports site
it's only the second time two players
with five all-star appearances each have
been swapped for each other the other
time was chris paul russell westbrook
so both these guys while polarizing are
clearly productive obviously there's
injury and health questions with john
wall
but what i'm fascinated by is just the
ripple effect because not only
does it like you said rearrange your
deck chairs and and the wizards look a
lot different in the rockets look a lot
different
but it also has a domino effect and a
ripple effect when it comes to okay
does this satisfy james harden who seems
hell-bent on playing with every star in
the nfl before his career is done
um is it does it satisfy harden and how
does this
affect his trade demands his reported
trade demands
or does he end up in brooklyn anyway at
some point right right and on the flip
side
the future of bradley beal is very much
in the balance
uh in washington you know what when you
think about it michael decides not to
stay
does he go and form a super team type
thing with play somewhere like miami who
knows you know what i do like the way
you've just rearranged the furniture i
got to let you get to your show i'm sure
your producers are saying where is he so
go sit down in that chair and we'll see
you
on nbc sports on peacock in less than a
few minutes thanks for the call
appreciate y'all man y'all take it easy
thank you
you got it that's michael smith you're
good fun shot right there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here